cnn puts out a hit piece on kamala
harris the economy should be booming but
it's not and americans are noticing i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit
expressvpn.com we'll get to all the news
in just one moment first let me remind
you that since time immemorial gold has
been the form of wealth that people have
sought after remember that time there
was a miller who promised a king that
his daughter could spin straw into gold
and then he locked her in a room to make
her spin gold one of the things that he
he didn't make her do is spin the straw
into united states government bonds and
the reason for that is because any time
you have centralized currency you got to
worry about the government doing exactly
what the government has been doing for
the last couple of years inflating the
living hell out of the currency in
pretty monumental news recently it was
recently announced social security
benefits are going to increase by 5.9
in january that is the highest increase
in 40 years that is the government
admitting inflation is out of control
and yet the left is still pushing
through trillions more in spending so
how are you protecting your savings from
inflation do what i do head on over to
birch gold group and now an incentive
for you to do so this month when you
text ben to 47 47 47 and purchase
precious metals with birch gold by
december 23rd you'll get free silver for
every five thousand dollars you invest
and yes you can convert an eligible ira
or 401k into an ira backed by precious
metals that qualifies as well birchgold
has an a plus rating with better
business bureau countless five-star
reviews thousands of happy customers
text ben 247 4747 for your free no
obligation information kit and holding
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account and to claim your free silver
with qualifying purchase by december
23rd text ben 247 47 47 protect your
savings today the same way that
rumpelstiltskin would alrighty so
let's talk about the fact that
joe biden made a big boo-boo he made a
big boo-boo right during the campaign he
was faced with the prospect of having to
pick a vice president
and
he had a lot of choices in front of him
he could pick somebody like amy
klobuchar he could have tacked it to the
center he could have picked somebody
like elizabeth warren who made the
hearts of progressives flutter
or he could try to please the
intersectional coalition by picking the
black lady
and he decided that he was going to
please the intersectional coalition by
picking a black lady but not just any
black lady a black lady who had attacked
him as a racist as a possible sexual
assaulter and also had been so terrible
as a campaigner that she had flamed out
completely before even her home state of
california could take a primary vote
kamala harris is a complete failure as a
politician
she's senator from california
essentially because any democrat who has
a warm body can win in california
and the only reason that she's vice
president of the united states right now
is because joe biden plucked her off the
ash heap of politics and decided to make
her vice president supposedly because he
needed somebody of color on the ticket
which of course is not true considering
that he had blown away bernie sanders in
the primaries specifically on the basis
of the black vote in places like south
carolina
so he made a boo-boo he essentially
signed blaine gabbert to a backup role
and then realized that blaine gabbert
was blaine gabbert
and now the leaks are a coming because
here is the thing joe biden is doing a
terrible job as president everybody
knows he's doing a terrible job as
president he's in the low 40s high 30s
in terms of approval rating and so
normally if you're a democrat you'd be
thinking okay fine so joe biden's going
to take the hit he's going to do all
these very progressive transformative
things and once he does these
progressive transformative things he's
going to step out of the way he will
take all of the cannon fire and then the
next person will step up into glory
because they will have this track record
of joe biden's pushing them forward they
will have this new remade american
economy that already exists they won't
get blamed for it they'll be walking
into a new status quo
shiny and ready to go there's only one
problem the person who is set to fill
joe biden's shoes once joe biden
shuffles off the stage on his walker
with the tennis balls on the bottom once
joe biden actually does that the person
standing behind him is kamal harris and
kamala harris has currently a 28
approval rating meaning everyone hates
her it's basically her and doug emhoff
are the kamala harris fan club that's
the entirety of it
no one likes her and so now you're
starting to see left-wing media turn on
kamala harris realizing that they've got
a dud on their hands and if joe biden
does not run in 2024 and kamala harris
does that's actually somehow a downgrade
do you understand how bad a candidate
you have to be to be a downgrade from
essentially a vegetable
you have a you have a president of the
united states who cannot get through a
full paragraph without stumbling all
over himself and or urinating in his own
pants and the person who is backing him
up is even less popular than that and by
the way not less popular because she's
out in the public eye doing unpopular
things
less popular because every time she pops
up her head in even the most minute
circumstance she alienates everyone
she is somehow less genuine than hillary
clinton
she is somehow less authentic than harry
reid
she is somehow more produced than a
busby berkeley musical
and everyone senses it i mean it's not
like he's been trotting her out and
she's been out there doing all sorts of
important things remember he promised he
was going to be co-president with her
and then after the first three weeks
when they realized how bad she is at
this they're like why don't you go pre
you cope why don't you go co-president
over here
in this closet under the stairs
like harry potter we'll just keep you
there for a few years we'll lock you in
matilda's chokey and then later we'll
take you out and maybe we'll run you for
president but it turns out that even
that is not enough to shield her from
the harsh glare of reality because every
time she comes out and says something
she looks terrible and so now the knives
are out and democrats are realizing that
they have to get rid of her and they
have to supplant her with someone else
now they have a really thin bench
they've been trying to promote p booty
judge the problem is that pete booty
judge just humiliated himself by going
completely mia
for two full months in the middle of a
supply chain crisis as the secretary of
transportation so he could take
paternity leave
which again
does not resonate i think with middle
americans the way that it resonates with
upper-class urban elites who went to
princeton i just i don't think that most
middle americans are like hold up hold
up a second i understand why my wife
gets maternity leave she had to push a
baby out of there but me getting
paternity leave for two full months on
the government i'm in the middle of a
supply chain crisis no
and especially because like if my wife
had to push something out of there and
then i had to care for her physically
because she actually had physical damage
that is a different thing then i get to
take two months off with brand new
babies when no one has any physical
damage because again people who judge is
married to a man and they
had these kids without any physical
damage being done right the purpose of
paternity leave traditionally speaking
is that dad can take care of mom while
mom takes care of baby that is the
actual purpose of paternity leave if
you're going to have paternity leave in
the first place it's not just because
you have to have bonding time with the
child
it is because it's a very if you've ever
if you've been married if you have kids
you understand it's a physically
damaging process to a woman to actually
have the baby
and then she needs help afterward but if
nobody needs help then why are you
taking off two months on the government
time not telling anybody and then we
realize you're gone so pete booty judge
has had a world of hurt and so he's been
attempting to now buy it back by
explaining
that really he's a hero for taking
paternity leave for two months and that
if everybody had paternity leave for two
months the economy would be better off
even though right now we have a massive
labor shortage in the country and
inflation up to wazoo and a supply chain
crisis in part facilitated by people
like pete booty judge okay so their
bench is super thin i think a common
harris who everyone hates pete booty
judge who is a lightweight
and who else who else
now the bite administration is trying
out like mitch landrieu i'm not kidding
you like the former governor of
louisiana they're like what if we'll put
him in charge of infrastructure maybe
we'll prop him up by having him stand in
front of a bridge or something maybe
he'll run
they are in such serious trouble so then
one thing they do know though is that
kamala harris has to go kamala harris
cannot be the person who runs in 2024.
we'll get to the cnn hit piece in a
second because it's so wonderful and so
telling me it really is hilarious first
let us talk about a simple fact if
you're a responsible person you need
life insurance i mean let's say that
you're a father and you have a son and
your son he's a bit of a nerd do well he
seems to be kind of a drunk and a
gambler and one day your son makes an
awful mistake he gets very upset with
this with this guy and he goes to his
house and he's and he shoots the guy's
dog
and it turns out that this guy happens
to be like the biggest master assassin
on planet earth well at this point you
might be thinking yourself man i should
have gotten life insurance for both me
and my son policy genius makes it easy
to compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
well you could say 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius
you could save 1300 or more per year on
life insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies the license experts and
policy genius work for you not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and buying process that
kind of service has earned policy genius
thousands of five star reviews across
trustpilot and google and eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week thanks to an award-winning
policy option that swaps the standard
medical exam requirement for a simple
phone call the exclusive policy was
recently rated number one by forbes
advisor higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow getting started is
simple head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro you can work out how much life
insurance coverage you need in just
minutes and then compare personalized
quotes to find your best price policy
genius does all the rest head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important to get it right
okay so this brings us to cnn's hit
piece and now i don't think that cnn
runs pretty much anything without
someone from the white house being
behind it i just don't think that's the
way cnn operates cnn is an adjunct wing
of the democratic press
press spokesperson essentially so
there's a piece there by edward isaac
doverer and jasmine wright it is titled
exasperation and dysfunction inside
kamala harris's frustrating start as
vice president oh it's gonna be good
guys do you see how the turnout is fair
play here everybody was thinking man i
was not ready for this this surprise
ending you know everybody thought that
when joe biden picked como harris he
would need a food taster because
like he wouldn't want to stand you
wouldn't want joe biden standing at the
top of the stairs of air force one and
kamala harris standing anywhere within
like a three foot radius right because
just one slip and uh and kamala harris
is president well what if it turns out
that joe biden has put out the
pre-emptive political hit on kamala
harris
wouldn't that be kind of glorious and
hilarious
well that may be what's happening and
yeah i'm here for it it's enjoyable worn
out by what they see as entrenched
dysfunction and lack of focus key west
wing aides have largely thrown up their
hands at vice president kamala harris
and her staff deciding there simply
isn't time to deal with them right now
especially at a moment when president
joe biden faces quickly multiplying
legislative and political concerns the
exasperation runs both ways interviews
with nearly three dozen former and
current harris aides administration
officials democratic operatives donors
and outside advisors who spoke
extensively to cnn reveal a complex
reality inside the white house many in
the vice president's circle fume she's
not being adequately prepared or
positioned and is instead being
sidelined
and the vp herself has told several
confidants she feels constrained in what
she's able to do politically
yeah they keep saying every time you go
out and get in front of a camera you
look like an idiot those around her
remain wary of even hinting at future
political ambitions with biden's team
highly attuned to signs of disloyalty
particularly from the vice president
she's a heartbeat away from the
presidency now she could be just a year
away from launching a presidential
campaign of her own given doubts
throughout the political world that
biden will actually go through with the
re-election bid in 2024 something he's
pledged to do both publicly and
privately yeah here's the other thing
joe biden doesn't want kamala harris
around because he sees her as a threat
and old joe still has the idea that he's
going to run for reelection and by run i
mean hobble toward re-election
few of the insiders who spoke with cnn
think she's being well prepared for
whichever role it will be by the way you
shouldn't have to well prepare the vp i
thought the entire idea was that the vp
is ready day one in case god forbid the
president goes down
i'm sorry this is not a tutoring class
you don't get like remedial vice
presidenting once you become vice
president of the united states you
should not be selecting somebody for
vice president of the i mean this is joe
biden's fault honestly you shouldn't be
selecting somebody for vice president
who needs like remedial math
if this is not you went to high school
and then they just passing you through
and then finally you graduated like 57th
in your class of 75 and uh and then you
get to community college and jill's
there teaching you how to do two plus
two equals four that's not what the vp
slot is supposed to be here
a few of the insiders who spoke with cnn
think she's being well prepared for
whichever role it will be
again i just i love the image of just
kamala hara sitting there and somebody's
standing in front of a blackboard
explaining to her what the vp role is
and how she's going to fulfill it
harris is struggling with a rocky
relationship with some parts of the
white house while longtime supporters
feel abandoned and see no coherent
public sense of what she's done or or
been trying to do as vice president
being the first woman and the first
woman of color in national elected
office is historic but has also come
with outside scrutiny and no forgiveness
for even small errors as she will often
point out
[Music]
by the way always a great look it
doesn't look peevish or whiny at all to
sit around as vice president of the
united states talking about how
everybody's mean to you oh it's so sad i
mean she doesn't get any forgiveness for
small errors now small error is like
saying that she's been to the border
when she hasn't been to the border ever
and not understanding why she should go
to the border for example or being
charged with getting coveted under
control and completely failing at that
literally everything she's tasked with
she fails at defenders and people who
care for harris are getting frantic says
cnn remember this is cnn this is not fox
news this is coming directly from biden
okay there's only one way that this
piece gets run and that is the white
house is looking out there and they are
saying she needs to go get rid of her
now we need another shot at this
defenders and people who care for harris
are getting frantic when they're annoyed
some pass around a recent onion story
mocking her lack of more substantive
work one with the headline white house
urges como harris to sit at computer all
day in case emails come through
when they're depressed they bat down the
aaron sorkin style rumor that biden
might try to replace her by nominating
her to a supreme court vacancy
that chatter has already reached top
levels of the biden orbit according to
one person who's heard it oh yeah good
luck with that
good luck with that nominating kamala
harris to the supreme court of the
united states based on her extensive
experience being terrible at everything
man talk about just failing upward this
would be the greatest example of failing
upward i've ever seen she fails as a g
in california by the way pushing the
totally unconstitutional and ridiculous
notion that the ag of a state can simply
refuse to defend a law in a given state
and then courts can simply refuse to
adjudicate the law this is what you do
with proposition 8. she said i'm an ag
of the state i don't like traditional
marriage the voters in my state like
traditional marriage i don't i refuse to
challenge
those i refuse to stand up for that law
in court and then the ninth circuit
court of appeal is like well if the
state of california isn't standing up
for its own law i guess we won't even
adjudicate it just ridiculous on his
face she's a garbage aj she was a
garbage senator this is when i was in
california so i know and now she's a
garbage vp and now they're like what if
we put her on the supreme court
we're gonna just if she keeps failing
will she eventually become a deity like
seriously we all have to sacrifice to
kamala harris we throw virgins into
volcanoes for kamala harris if she keeps
failing this way we'll just keep moving
her up the food chain until we all
genuflect at the actual altar of kamala
harris based on her sucking at her job
royally it's unbelievable
by the way apparently this is like a
thing in democratic party politics terry
mcauliffe just lost his virginia
governor's race which is nearly
impossible to do you know how hard you
have to work as a democrat to lose
virginia gubernatorial race you have to
work super hard at it
and i'll say this for terry mccall if
you worked super hard at losing that
dude was dedicated to losing he lost to
glenn juncken first thing that happened
the bite administration came around
knocking on his door saying do you want
to be in the biden administration like
the failure upward is just astoni joe
biden is a great story of this right joe
biden ran for president 173 times he's
been running for president since william
jennings bryant was challenging him in
primaries and now joe biden is president
of the united states you can just keep
failing upward presumably
according to cnn harris is perceived to
be in such a weak position that top
democrats in and outside of washington
have begun to speculate privately asking
each other why the white house has
allowed her to become so hobbled in the
public consciousness at least as they
see it again i love that her own
failings are now jobiden's fault
joe biden is a dodding old fool and the
biden team's like why can't why can't he
help her and she was like
and then he falls over and clocks his
head
and we'll continue on this because it's
glorious it really is
talk about dysfunctional okay as i've
said before
when it comes to politics folks
understand politics is never house of
cards it is always veep it is never
house of cards it is always v but it's a
bunch of morons running around like
chickens with their head cut off
directly into walls until they knock
themselves unconscious and then tax you
that is what american politics is and
politics of nearly every sort
i'll get some more on this in just one
second first let us talk about how you
sleep at night okay so reality when you
listen to talk about politics might make
you a little upset might make it a
little angry but when you lay your head
on the pillow at night you want to go to
sleep well one thing you don't think
about is your sheet quality right you
need great sheets and this is why you
need a bull and branch bowling branch is
the perfect holiday gift it never
disappoints with the highest quality
sheets blankets pillows and throws plus
their holiday packaging makes your gifts
look and feel special husband and wife
team scott at missy 10 and found it
bolin brand should create a new standard
in bedding by doing things the right way
not the easy way bowlin branch holds
themselves to high standards across the
board and it's not just their sheets
that are made the right way their
pillows bath towels robes they're all
made just a top quality
i love my bowling brand sheets in fact
they're so good i got rid of all of our
other sheets seriously like we only
sleep on bowling branch at this point
signature hem sheets are their all-time
bestseller their beloved for a lot of
reasons like how they get softer with
every single wash they're buttery soft
lightweight made with 100 organic cotton
weave that feels incredible in all
seasons treat yourself and your loved
ones to the new standard bedding from
bowling branch their gifts come wrapped
and ready in their special holiday
packaging order by december 19th for
guaranteed delivery by christmas get up
20 off your order from today through
november 17th with promo code shapiro at
bowlandbranch.com that's b-o-l-l and
branch dot com promo code shapiro see
site for details exclusions may apply go
check them out right now
bullanbranch.com use promo code shapiro
for their special deal alright so cnn
story this hit piece on kamala harris
continues
quote she's very honored and very proud
to be vice president of the united
states her job as the number two is to
be helpful and supportive to the
president and to take on work that he
asks her to take on sedolini quinnilakis
the lieutenant governor of california a
longtime friend cloonalacka spoke with
the vp last monday morning before harris
departed for a diplomatic mission to
france it is natural that those of us
who know her know how much more helpful
she can be than she is currently being
asked to be said kunalakis that's where
the frustration is coming from
an incumbent vice president says cnn
should be a shoe-in the next time the
party's presidential nomination is open
but guessing who might launch a
theoretical primary challenge to harris
has become an ongoing insider parlor
game other politicians with their own
presidential ambitions have started
privately acknowledging they're trying
to figure out how to quietly lay the
groundwork to run if and when harris
falters as they think she might
the reality is more complex and looks
different to people more familiar with
how any white house actually works
harris is the first vp in decades to
come into office with less washington
experience than the president finding
her footing was always going to be hard
oh
so sad
presidents and vice presidents and their
staffs often clash barack obama's west
wing tended to be dismissive of biden
staffers and biden himself had a number
of stumbles early in that job
republicans and right-wing media turned
harrison to a political target from the
moment she was picked for the ticket and
implicit
racism and
sexism have been constant
that's it's not that she sucks at her
job it's racism and sexism that's that's
the solution hey by the way joe biden
picked her for racism and sexism why a
victor openly i need a black woman for
the job he said and thus he picked a
black woman i don't know who's being the
racist in the sexist other than the guy
who literally said he's selecting on the
basis of race and sex
but says cnn it's a conundrum unique to
her people are expecting their historic
vice president to make history every day
when in fact she's trying to carry the
duties of a secondary role harris is
being judged not just by how she's doing
in the traditional duties of a vice
president
said minion moore a long time democratic
operative who's become harris's most
important outside advisor it's a little
more subliminal but it's real what's her
playbook in history said
harris has emerged as a quiet force in
the administration said more oh is that
and she focuses attention on different
issues sometimes just by her very
presence in the room
oh
that's a good way of putting
in the corner and say nothing and wear
the dunce cap please
she's a quiet force in the
administration that's amazing you know
uh this kleenex box right here it's a
quiet force on my show it's been sitting
right here on the table this whole time
doing pretty much nothing but you know
really this is this kleenex box right
here
i think it's been having a market impact
on the quality of the show it doesn't
have to have any kleenex in it by the
way i think it's empty i think we need a
new kleenex box but it's been doing it
it's doing a it's a quiet force it
focuses attention on different issues
just by its very presence in the room
love it love it that is a hot take right
there from minion more her quiet
presence in the room just standing there
like a thing
um
uh i love this too uh it's so good okay
the story just gets better from cnn with
many sources speaking on condition of
anonymity to discuss the situation more
frankly they all tell roughly the same
story harris's staff has repeatedly
failed her and left her exposed stalin
has never failed only stalin's staff has
failed him
to the bianca with you
yes
um
that you harris cannot fail harris can
only be failed
even some who have been asked for advice
lament harris's overly cautious
tendencies and staff problems which have
been a feature of every office she's
held from san francisco d.a to u.s
senate
cnn continues biden aimed to model his
relationship with harris on his own vice
presidency and directed aides early in
his presidency to employ her in similar
fashion he arranged weekly lunches just
as he'd held with obama and invited
herod and invited harris to join him for
his morning classified intelligence
briefing harris meanwhile threw herself
into proving her commitment to the
president and the administration using
his relationship with obama as her guide
even then some white house aides
questioned whether biden's experiences
vp would easily translate to someone
with far different qualifications and
skills and to a much different moment
after harris became known in the first
few months were often standing by
biden's side in the frame as he made big
speeches even after she'd introduced him
herself the white house the west wing
appears to have overcorrected
so she's been with the president
noticeably less not just in public a
week and a half ago as biden and his
aides and multiple outside allies
rattled through calls all day trying to
lock down wavering lawmakers ahead of
the house infrastructure vote harris
spent the afternoon touring a nasa space
flight center in suburban maryland we
weren't going to cancel her schedule
just because of the house's foolishness
a harrison explained
um well alternatively the white house
was like yeah we don't need you in in
the room making calls to people if you'd
like to go see the spaceships and the
nice telescope and and we can hire some
kids so they look excited that happened
they literally hired children to be in
the room with her that's how popular she
is that's that's exciting stuff they
were like actual that was reported so
good times over there with kamala harris
the next morning biden singled her out
saying a lot of this has to do with the
lady right here the vice president but
that's not how things have played out
no indeed it is not we'll get to more of
this in a moment yes we're going to go
through the complete collapse of kamala
harris in excruciating detail because
this is the hit okay the democrats it's
so funny they're trying to buy it back
they're trying to be like no
they keep saying that it's really about
others failing her
but um
no it is not it is that she is uh she is
a complete failure and this is joe
biden's fault and it's it's just
wonderful to watch we'll get some more
of it in just one second first let's
talk again about that sleep quality i
already talked about sheets now you need
like the actual mattress right you need
a mattress that is made just for you at
the end of a long day you want to crash
onto your helix slate mattress helix
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep everybody's unique
helix knows that they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they've got soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus sized sleepers
it's such a great mattress i actually
got one for my sister for her wedding it
is a fantastic fantastic gift they have
a 10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix has financing options
flexible payment plans a great night's
sleep is never far away i took the helix
slip quiz i got a firm mattress that's
really breathable which is exactly what
i need just go to helixleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
ben okay so back to this cnn hit piece
on kamala harris so
apparently joe biden had basically
shuffled her off to nasa to hang out
with the children and then he brought
her back and he's like she she
contributed a lot she she you know she
she really helped me out
but so cnn that's not exactly how things
had played out
while she had attended some meetings
biden hosted with key lawmakers there
were many more she didn't attend to the
point it was noteworthy she made another
schedule drop by one session in the
final stretch harris had only been in
washington four years to the white house
just one time before being sworn in as
vp
so in other words she didn't know any of
the senators and no one cared about her
and no one liked her so sending her to
the hill was completely pointless
harris's aides cite how much of what's
in the infrastructure bill connects back
to legislation she worked on well in the
senate including accessible broadband
wildfire defense water cleanup and clean
energy school buses ooh school buses
perhaps one harris aid offered
the issue is that some in the west wing
don't have constant knowledge of what
the vps team is doing we feel like a
central component of the effort overall
another said
harris has also complained to confidence
about not being a greater part of the
president's approach to the afghanistan
withdrawal despite telling cnn at the
time she was the last one in the room
when he made the decision leaving her
without more to draw on when she
defended him publicly
wait so she she's so politically
incompetent she wanted to be closer to
the center of the afghanistan withdrawal
that is something like that that line
right there tells you everything you
need to know about kamala harris's
political instincts
joe biden destroyed his presidency on
the shoals of afghanistan he decided to
precipitously withdraw from afghanistan
leave hundreds of american citizens
behind leave tens of thousands of siv
holders behind leave 19 million women's
the predations of the taliban and kamala
harris is like why can't i be in the
room for that why can't i be at the
center of that
man this lady has the political
instincts of a badger trying to cross
the i-5
like very bright bright
when harris picked her when biden picked
harris as his running mate who's
essentially anointing her as the future
of the democratic party says cnn
now many of those close to her feel like
he's shirking his political duties to
promote her essentially setting her up
to fail her fans are panicked by her
fans we mean her and doug m hoff again
watching her poll numbers sink even
lower than biden's worrying that even
the base democratic vote is starting to
give up on her
says a top donor to biden and other
democrats quote kamala harris is a
leader but is not being put in positions
to lead that doesn't make sense we need
to be thinking long term we need to be
doing what's best for the party you
should be putting her in positions to
succeed
on the one hand on one issue harris is
actually asked to be assigned voting
rights progress has been slow because
biden is focused on passing his own
domestic agenda even though harris has
said privately the filibuster must be
scaled back if real progress can be
achieved
and though harris has told confidence
she's been enjoying a good working
dynamic directly with biden those who
work for them describe their
relationship in terms of settling into
an exhausted stalemate
suspicion says cnn has sprouted out of
bitterness last month white house aides
left to the defense of transportation
secretary p buddha judge
harris loyalists tell cnn they see in
that yet another example of the unfair
standard to play wondering why she
didn't get similar cover any of the
times she's been attacked by the right
it's hard to miss the specific energy
the white house brings to defend a white
man knowing that kamala harris has spent
almost a year taking a lot of the hits
the west wing didn't want to take
themselves instead of former harris aide
so now come it's going to be so much fun
guys this booty judge is going to run
running against her and it's going to be
kamal harris being like you only like
booty judge because he's white and puja
is going to be like you only like humble
harris because she's straight
it's gonna be intersectional joy all the
way down it'll be lots of fun
white house aides said they weren't
pitting one against the other the
difference in the responses those aids
think was that buddha judge hadn't done
anything wrong
who do judges leave was a conveniently
timed reminder that biden is pushing for
a national paid leave law that's
different from when harris has created
problems for herself white house aides
believe such as when she didn't push
back on a student who accused israel of
ethnic genocide west wing aids weren't
going to clean up after that
but even when white house has faced her
own manufactured outrage from the right
like when an innocuous tweet about
enjoying the long memorial day weekend
was said to be insulting dead veterans
white house aides also remained
virtually silent
and then cnn continues along these lines
harris's team is mad biden assigned her
to handle diplomatic relations with the
northern triangle nations in the hopes
of addressing root causes of migration
but gave her no role on the southern
border itself
as cnn has previously reported harris
herself has said she didn't want to be
assigned to manage the border aware that
it was a no-win political situation that
would only sandbag her in the future but
biden's team was annoyed that harris
kept fumbling answers about the border
as some around heresy at the white house
failed to come to her defense
biden aids have repeatedly told herself
they'd love to have her they'd love to
have her doing more and asked the vp's
office to come up with plans for how to
get her involved according to people
familiar with the conversations
though the staffs are on multiple calls
per week west wing aides are often left
wondering why there's not more follow
through
aware of her stumblings and the ticking
political clock harris's chief of staff
tina florina went to ron clayne over the
summer they were drowning and they
needed more help clayne is known as a
kamala harris defender in the west wing
this is the chief of staff and does a
weekly one-on-one meeting with her in
the west wing office to help her
strategize as a former chief of staff to
two vps claim knows the dynamics well
claine in a statement provided to cnn
downplayed any criticism of the vp
saying harris and her team are quote off
to the fastest and strongest start of
any vp i have seen
[Music]
harris's aide's point that biden was
never subjected to the kind of attacks
she regularly or endures or to a toxic
social media culture
and then they say it's because she's too
loyal to biden that's the big problem
she is too loyal to biden
and then she starts blaming her aides
in and around harris's circle they
speculate there must be someone getting
in her way something against the
president himself leaving her out in the
cold some blame specific west wing aides
who they feel are out to con whom they
feel sure are out to undercut her some
fear the vice president is leaning
heavily on her sister maya
brother-in-law tony west and niece mina
harris whom they sense exerting
influence over everything from sapphires
to political decisions
several people familiar with the
operations of the vp say that after a
spike in involvement earlier in the year
the family has now been pushed further
out again recently if you expect that to
remain the case
so again she's blaming her operation you
have everybody in the white house
blaming her
you have
her falling apart on the public stage
and um she is she's just falling apart
she's falling apart
donna brazile one of seven several
prominent black women who urged biden
advisors to put harris on the ticket
agreed that it's time to retweet after a
rough first year brazil wants to see the
vp on the road almost constantly keep
air force too gassed up and ready to go
she joked whether talking about
replacing lead pipes in flint or
expanding broadband in rural america
she's a wonderful messenger but it has
to be clear concise and consistent said
brazil don't make her a creature of the
beltway let her out yeah that's the
issue is that they've been we haven't
seen enough of kamala hair so here's the
funny part the bite administration is
desperately trying to downplay this how
do we know so jen saki
who is back from her coveted bout she
was fine she tweeted out
there's a direct quote for anyone who
needs to hear it vp is not only a vital
partner to potus but a bold leader who
has taken on key important challenges
facing the country from voting rights to
addressing root causes of migration to
expanding broadband
[Music]
oh yes there's that energy gotta love
that energy we are so happy we picked up
that blaine gabbert to be our our backup
quarterback now that tom brady is is
injured this is gonna go just great we
love her we love her
yeah things are going great over here
blaine gabbert will definite we're not
gonna pick up anyone from the waiver
wire lane gabbard is definitely gonna be
our long time starting quarterback yeah
hmm
chen's hockey really trying to tweet
through it ron clean doing the same
thing so we're on clean chief of staff
and just retweeted something from a
person named robert garcia our vp kamala
harris just finished a highly successful
trip where she strengthened diplomatic
relationships she takes on the most
complex assignment because she's capable
and smart she's a great leader who also
happens to be funny and kind and that's
the tweet and ronald mclean retweeted
that
so team biden is like okay we're okay
we're gonna pretend that we like her
yeah we hate her we're going to pretend
okay sure so
the fact that kamala harris is in a
complete state of implosion and that you
have a giant several thousand word long
story at cnn about the complete
implosion of common harris demonstrates
the democrats are in such serious
trouble they are in the biggest trouble
right now and they know it i mean
they're in serious how serious is the
trouble the democrats are in
according to a brand new abc news
washington post poll
republican congressional candidates in
the generic ballot currently hold their
biggest lead
in 40 years
in four decades is the biggest lead
since before i was born in the
congressional generic ballot
the democratic party's difficulties
according to abc news are deep they
include soaring economic discontent a
president who's following 12 percentage
points under water and job approval and
a broad sense the party is out of touch
with the concerns of most americans 62
say so
and this is the worst number for the
democratic party they're down at 41
in the history of the poll
about as many people see the republican
party as out of touch
president biden's keystone policy
initiatives might be more popular than
he is but
he's getting no credit for it only 31
percent of americans say that biden is
keeping his major campaign promises 35
think he's accomplishing much overall
59 worry he'll do too much to increase
the size and role of government that's
up six points since the spring
as things stand if the midterms were
around today 51 percent of registered
voters say they would support the
republican candidate in the
congressional district 41 say the
democrat
by the way that's among registered
voters not likely voters in the midterms
likely voters can attend more republican
that lead is smaller than what the vote
will end up being if that hold
55 of americans disapprove of biden's
economic performance that is six percent
higher than any approval rating for
donald trump six percent higher than any
disapproval rating for donald trump
okay remember in september 2017
donald trump's disapproval rating on the
economy was 49
and then he lost 40 seats in the house
so what's gonna happen to the democrats
will there be democrats in the house at
all if these polls hold because joe
biden is wildly unpopular and the
democrats were betting okay fine he'll
do the wildly unpopular thing he'll
restructure the american economy and
then he'll hand it over to kamala except
now they're looking they're going uh oh
they're doing the kamala harris
phase
it's it's not yeah it's not going to be
good and somewhere kamala harris laughs
super duper awkwardly
there is no bump for joe biden from the
infrastructure bill they keep trying to
make infrastructure a thing fetch is not
going to be a thing 70 percent of
americans rate the economy as not so
good or poor
and this is this just it's bad news for
the democrats
like really bad news and the economic
news continues to be underwhelming we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let's talk about the underwear that
currently grace yortokas i can tell you
the underwear that grace this
magnificent took us are tommy john
underwear they are just that good
because they deserve to be worn on this
magnificent time you're underwear super
comfortable really durable lightweight
breathable
again it is the best tommy john is just
the best you're not going to want any
other underwear after you try tommy john
you'll feel the same level of comfort
layering their luxuriously soft
loungewear right on top as well it's
comfortable it's good looking you can
and you will be wearing them anywhere
that's why tommy john doesn't have
customers they have fanatics with over
96 4 star plus reviews and over 16
million pairs sold you have to try tommy
john for yourself plus it's all backed
by that tommy john best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee get 20
percent off your first order right now
at tommyjohn.com
that's tommyjohn.com
for 20 off
see site tommyjohn.com details again
time john is so good that once you try
other underwear it's gonna be very
difficult to go back to those ones that
bunch up and are uncomfortable and they
break down in the washing machine not so
with tommy john go check them out right
now tommyjohn.com slash ben get 20 off
your first order today alrighty we'll
get to more on the economy in just a
moment and joe biden and his
administration trying to tweet through
it basically
first as the legacy media continue to
report their version of the news our
newest podcast morning wire continues
topping the apple and spotify charts
we've continued our commitment to
bringing you the news without a hidden
agenda it's the only daily podcast that
values your time and the truth while
we're working overtime to bring you the
news you need to know we need your help
to keep the facts trending toward number
one so subscribe start listening right
now to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so while joe biden is flailing
in the polls the economy continues to
flounder according to the uk daily mail
a record 4.4 million americans quit
their jobs in september
apparently they were doing so to fill
other positions but what this means that
people aren't really getting back into
the workforce at the rate they need to
be people are leaving some jobs and
they're filling other jobs which means
the jobs they just left are now open
according to the uk daily mail americans
quit their jobs at a record pace for the
second straight month in september in
many cases for more money elsewhere as
companies bump up pay to fill job
openings that are close to an all-time
high the us department of labor
announced on friday that 4.4 million
people about three percent of the
nation's workforce quit their jobs in
september that's up from 4.3 million in
august far above the pre-pandemic level
of 3.6 million there were still 10.4
million job openings the figures come on
the heels of wednesday's consumer price
index which revealed the cost of living
up 6.2 in october 21 from one year prior
is at its highest level in 31 years
so
joe biden is celebrating all of this but
people are quitting jobs to go to other
jobs they are not getting back into the
workforce we are going to create for
ourselves a permanent underclass and at
some point by the way if you can't fill
the jobs you're going to be unable to
keep your business open
okay as the wall street journal points
out the slow return of prime age workers
is threatening the recovery
the share of people working or looking
for a job has stagnated in recent months
the participation rate was 61.6 in
october up from a steep decline at the
onsen to the pandemic still well below
63.3 in february of 2020 just before
covet 19 hit the us economy
roughly 1.4 million fewer adults aged 25
to 54 are working or looking for a job
than the month before the pandemic hit
labor force participation rate for these
so-called prime age workers was 81.7
percent this october down from 82.9 in
february 2020.
and if people keep staying out of the
workforce it's going to be very
difficult to ramp up production
necessary to curb inflation
now you got the bite administration
again they just keep trying to tweet
through this stuff what i mean by that
is that it's like baghdad bob
not enough people are going back into
the workforce
and a lot of people are quitting and so
you have the white house economic
advisor jared bernstein saying you know
people quitting is probably a good thing
like we like why shouldn't we be
positive about that
well i'm glad you asked because it's uh
often misinterpreted as a bad sign when
from a worker's perspective it's
actually a good sign the reason it's a
good sign is because at a time of very
strong labor demand 5.6 million jobs
created since this president got here
620 000 per month historical records the
unemployment rate falling faster than it
has in in over in over 50 years so that
those kinds of conditions mean that
there are lots of good higher paying
opportunities for workers to engage in
upward mobility and that's what the quit
rates are telling us at a time like this
people are not quitting and leaving the
labor market they're mostly quitting so
that they can move up the scale to a
better job okay and uh you know what
else is happening the jobs they just
left are unoccupied and people aren't
going back into the workforce at the
rate that they need to be going back
into the workforce of which is creating
a shortage of supply and the reason you
get inflation is because you have too
much money that is chasing too few goods
okay so yes you have a supply chain
bottleneck but you don't have people
getting back into the workforce fast
enough because we incentivized them to
stay home because we paid them to stay
home because we blew money into the
system at an overwhelming rate for the
last two years and a lot of people are
still living off that money at this
point
okay and it's going to get even worse if
the democrats get what they want which
is heavy regulations and heavy taxation
so there is a formula that is quite
famous about
prices and inflation okay the formula
goes something like this okay it is mv
equals pt this is brought to us by our
friend david bonson who has a brand new
book out you should go check it out he's
an economist okay mv equals pt
m is higher money supply
v is velocity meaning how fast is the
money passing through the economy okay
so when you multiply those together
that gives you the price
times the supply so price time supply
equals the amount of money in the system
times the velocity so what that means is
that if you have really really high
money supply the prices are going to go
up
the only way they won't go up is if you
have is if you have tremendous
generation of supply if you've got high
money and high velocity you better have
really really high supply or you're
going to get increased prices that's
just the way the formula works the
problem right now is that the bite
administration is doing two things one
they're blowing more money into the
economy with m
and two they're lowering the amount of
supply how are they lowering the amount
of supply first of all you have the
supply chain crisis but second of all
the supply of product is dependent on
investment in the economy are people
hiring are people going to continue to
hire even when the taxes kick in and the
regulations kick in
joe biden wants to tax living hell out
of everything that moves
if
the idea is regulated while it lives and
tax it until it dies that is the vitamin
administration philosophy
that is going to that is going to create
serious economic blowback including
increased stag inflation
right that is why you are getting
inflation right now is because of lack
of supply so what are they doing they're
trying to restrict supply apparently
by saying that it is good that there are
not enough people in the workforce it's
an act of good
not only that they're trying to pass
more regulations and more taxation which
is going to cut down on the ability of
people to invest in the economy thereby
generating the new supply
but again the bite administration keeps
on trying to tweet through it so you got
by the economist jared bernstein saying
that build back better which is all
taxes and all regulation is going to put
downward pressure on inflation in what
magical world is this going to happen
are you an insane person
when it comes to
building back better when it comes to
the infrastructure plan these are
measures and this isn't as well
understood as it needs to be that will
put downward pressure on inflation
that's not just me talking you have
economists like larry summers saying
this mark zandy from moody's economics
saying this we have 17 nobel laureates
signing a letter that says and i'm going
to quote here that these bills that will
enhance the ability of more americans to
participate productively in the economy
it will ease longer-term inflationary
pressure
okay no one thinks really this is going
to ease longer term inflationary
pressure not if you are restructuring
the economy with regulation and taxation
while blowing money into the economy
it's like the worst available policy but
again they're going to keep tweeting
through you got the white house national
economic council director brian d saying
we need buildback better more cowbell
more
how concerned are you and the president
about inflation and what specifically
are you doing to fix it well inflation
is high right now and it is affecting
consumers in their pocketbook and also
in their outlook for the economy
but those concerns underscore why
it's so important that we move forward
on the build back better legislation
this legislation that the house is going
to consider this week
these people are out of their damn minds
they're out of their minds again the
administration's solution to
too little supply and too much money in
the system is more money supply and
let's tax anybody who seeks to invest in
the system it's crazy it's crazy i mean
they're nominating people like their new
treasury
their new treasury nominees hello marova
who's supposed to oversee banking this
is a person who has openly said in the
past she wants to get rid of bank
account deposits yeah nothing is going
to gin up investment in the economy by
getting rid of bank account deposits
which the banks then use in order to do
fractional reserve banking right lend
out the money so that people can
actually invest get rid of that it'll be
great here's cellular again there's a
person who's been nominated by the body
administration to oversee banking in the
united states it's crazy
to imagine what would it be like if
instead of being just a public option
for deposit banking this would be
actually
the full transition in other words there
will be no more private uh bank deposit
accounts and all of the deposit accounts
will be held directly at the fed
they're totally crazy they're out of
their minds okay larry summers again a
democrat former treasury secretary under
bill clinton who now looks like a
moderate republican by today's standards
larry summers was lighting up the biden
white house on inflation as well he
should
look they forecast that inflation would
be two percent this year in the
president's budget
it's three times that
they said in the summer time
after they'd been initially wrong
that inflation would be
back to normal by the end of the year
then they said early in the fall that
inflation would subside
early next year now they're saying that
it's going to subside in the second half
of uh next year
that does not sound transitory gang that
sounds like that is a permanent feature
of american public life and i don't know
what the borderline between transitory
and permanent is in american politics i
can tell you that it ain't two years
okay like come on come on
and meanwhile the good news is the media
are gonna tweet through it with them so
msnbc's stephanie rule she says here's
the good news you guys can infor you can
afford inflation it's fine you're fine
stop whining
but you have to put all this in
perspective this inflation is not in
isolation and the government predicted
it was going to be a challenging
recovery recovery all tied to covid so
it's why you see things like that
expanded child tax credit you've got the
families of over 60 million kids on
average getting 430 dollars a month for
people on fixed incomes older people on
social security they're getting those
fixed payments adjusted next year up 5.9
percent for inflation and the dirty
little secret here willie while nobody
likes to pay more on average we have the
money to do so
okay on average we don't wages are not
rising as fast as inflation is everyone
knows it
but you know what when you got to push
the agenda you got to push the agenda
okay so there are unforeseen
consequences to the kind of democratic
behavior that we are seeing right now
hilariously there's only one group of
people who are really benefiting from
the inflation and it's state and local
governments okay so state and local
governments are raking in the tax
dollars according to the wall street
journal one irony of inflation is that
while it's bad for working americans
it's great for the government tax
revenues soar as nominal profits and
incomes rise and for evidence simply
look at the boom in state and local
government coffers they've rarely had it
so good but don't expect them to be
frugal spenders overall state and local
government receipts including federal
aid were 23 percent above pre-pandemic
levels in the third quarter through
september thanks to congress's gusher of
spending and the strong economic
recovery according to the committee for
a responsible federal budget
property corporate sales and individual
tax revenue from the third quarter of
2020 through the second quarter of this
year is running 18.3 percent above the
same period two years ago
how many americans have seen their
incomes rise almost 20 percent over the
last two years
like a lot of us
progressive states are doing especially
well they're whining about how they
don't have enough money they have plenty
of money
state and local tax revenue in new york
is running 13.3 billion dollars that's
21.3 percent higher for the current
fiscal year that began in april over the
same period in 2019 and by the way 2019
was a good year
california continues to report record of
monthly tax collections
and these rich states are receiving
plenty of welfare from from washington
congress has now given states and local
governments 885 billion dollars in
direct aid through various covet bills
for schools public transit medicaid and
more and now they're about to get
another helping from the infrastructure
deal
remember last year the states were
saying they were going to go bankrupt
yeah it was all a lie it's not true
and of course the federal government is
about to dump four trillion dollars more
in if they get billed back better pass
you can see why so many democrats are in
favor of all of this there's only one
problem it completely destroys economic
innovation it completely destroys the
ability of people to invest so great
exchange hilarious exchange between
bernie sanders and elon musk on twitter
yesterday so bernie sanders did his
usual thing okay bernie sanders says
this thing on twitter he says the world
is full of unfair things that happen all
the time
i like fair things and i don't like
unfair things and said things are bad
bad things are bad and then everybody in
his they go yay bernie
okay so that is bernie's twitter account
so bernie tweeted out we must demand
that they're extremely lucky paid their
fashion period and bring me pudding we
must demand the extremely wealthy pay
their fair share now we've discussed ad
nauseam on this program how much the
wealthy pay in the united states and
it's all met income taxes in the united
states like all of it okay but
there's only one problem when you tell
people they have to pay their fair share
and when bernie sanders says fair share
he means pretty much everything
everybody knows so elon musk tweeted out
i keep forgetting you're still alive
harsh stuff there from uh from elon musk
boom
okay and then he follows up there he
follows up on that one
and he says
would you like me to sell some more of
my stock because this is what he did
he says want me to sell more stock
bernie just say the word
he says bernie is a taker not a maker
this is correct okay so the the bernie
sanders economic agenda the democratic
economic agenda hurts the economy it
makes inflation worse it creates
economic stagnation
they know this by the way so they have
to come up with an excuse the excuse
they're coming up with for their own
failed economic policy is alternatively
apparently kamala harris he's just being
taken and sacrificed to the great gods
of joe biden's political ambition
or covid right they keep blaming coveted
so you had the white house national
economic council director
brian diese saying you know what all the
problems we're seeing right now they're
not joe biden's fault they're kovid's
fault now here's the thing they're not
covet fault i know because i live in a
state where everybody is going about
their daily business like everything is
normal because it's normal now
but apparently it's all kovid's fault
certainly we saw just as the delta
variant
posed real health challenges to the
economy i'd also had economic impacts
more people were consuming goods at home
watching tv rather than buying a new
television rather than going out to the
movies and spending on services and so
that's added to some of the supply chain
challenges that we face but we're seeing
these price increases as inflation
globally because of the supply chain
challenges associated with uh kovit
that's why we're going right at
attacking those issues right now as well
so great it's all covered they're going
directly at the cove issues so how are
they going to solve culverts so they
said they're going to solve the economy
and they proceeded to
basically act like a monkey scoring a
basketball
that is the modern economic policy a
monkey just going to town on basketball
so now they've done the same thing
uncovered remember that time that joe
biden said he wasn't gonna shut down the
economy he was gonna shut down the virus
remember that time and he shut down the
economy and not shut down the virus so
his plan has been that he's gonna force
every employer in america to force their
employees to get vaccinated that's only
one problem you're looking at countries
all over the all over the world and they
have very high vaccination rates and
they are still having breakthrough cases
and people who are unvaccinated are
still getting sick
that's just the way life is you got to
make your choice and then live with it
and go back to work and live your life
end of story but joe biden wants to be
seen as the guy who can fix all these
problems even though
again monkey basketball
that does not make for a successful
mating
strategy okay so he's done that again on
the economy now it's a monkey screwing a
basketball on covid
and um and it's a complete failure but i
think that he means for it to be a
complete failure because all he wants is
just not to be blamed so over the
weekend a federal appeals court in new
orleans according to the washington post
halted the biden administration's
vaccine or testing requirement for
private businesses delivering another
political setback to one of the white
house's signature public health policies
a three-judge panel of the u.s court of
appeals for the fifth circuit helmed by
one judge appointed by president reagan
and two others appointed by trump issued
the ruling friday after temporarily
halting the mandate last weekend calling
the requirement to mandate the court
said the rule instituted through the
labor department grossly exceeds osha's
statutory authority
rather than delica rather than a
delicately handled scalpel the mandate
is a one-size-fits-all sledgehammer that
makes hardly any attempt to account for
differences in workplaces and workers
that have more than a little bearing on
workers varying degrees of
susceptibility to the supposedly grave
danger the mandate purports to address
the mandate imposes a financial burden
upon them by deputizing their
participation in osha's regulatory
scheme exposes them to severe financial
risk if they fail to comply and
threatens to decimate their workforces
and business prospects by forcing
unwilling employees to take their shots
take their tests or hit the road
and that's in the fifth circuit we have
our lawsuit here at daily wire against
the obama administration in the sixth
circuit court of appeals and the
administration is going to fail here
it's just going to fail
according to the air force times the new
commander of the oklahoma national guard
has now declared the organization will
not enforce dod's covenant vaccine
mandate on its troops army brigadier
general thomas manchino was announced as
the state's new adjutant general
wednesday that he has not yet been
confirmed by the state senate on
november 2nd st
instead is the governor of of oklahoma
kevin stead he formally requested that
dod not enforce the mandate on the
state's army and air national guard
members in the letter which his office
posted online he said that 10 of the
state's troops had refused the vaccine
and that the mandate was irresponsible
so the pentagon
has said that they will respond
appropriately
the state's former top general army
major general michael thompson told
local reporters thursday he learned who
his replacement was via social media
that after taking the reins from
thompson manchino issued a policy memo
declaring the state would not enforce
the mandate on its troops when they are
under state control
so they are not going to be deputized by
the federal government to do joe biden's
vaccine mandate
meanwhile over in florida ron desantis
is bringing back florida lawmakers to
crack down on pandemic mandates
according to the washington post a
special legislative session dubbed keep
florida free begins today at the behest
of governor desantis who wants lawmakers
to pass more measures to block covet
vaccine mandates by public and private
employers the four bills being
considered would ratchet up the
penalties for businesses local
governments and other entities that
require workers to be vaccinated against
the virus and students to our masks in
schools according to desantis the
session will strengthen as well as
augment rules already in place in part
through his own executive orders
he said at the end of the day we want
people to be able to make informed
decisions for themselves we've got to
stop but we've got to stop bossing
people around we've got to stop the
coercion we've got to stop trying to
browbeat people he said we're going to
be striking a blow for freedom
so some republicans are saying that
they're not super happy with this but
the bottom line is that
the breakdown read to blue is that red
states wish to be free and go about
their daily business and blue states
apparently wish to lock down forever and
be subject to the whims of people like
joe biden
and it's complete failure okay all of
this is really unpopular
it's really unpopular the democrats by
the way have settled on their midterm
strategies so you might be looking at
all this and thinking yourself my god
they're just going to get shellacked
what exactly is their plan here
like what is their plan for 2022 2024
tomorrow harrison beat booty judge for
2024.
inflation economic stagnation and vax
mandates for 2022 like what exactly is
the plan here well the good news is that
politico now has a copy of the
democratic playbook for 2022 2024 you
ready for this
quote most measures suggest that
democrats are very likely to lose
control of the house next year so we
were eager to get the first look at a
memo the dccc the democratic
congressional campaign committee is
releasing this morning on the state of
play a little less than one year out
from election day the positive case for
returning democrats to power is their
legislative agenda the passage of the
american rescue plan to tackle the
pandemic fail the infrastructure bill
and they hope the buildback better
agenda it's going nowhere but there's a
ton of data in history that make it
clear new presidents often don't get
rewarded by voters for their legislative
achievements in their first midterm
do democrats have a backup plan they do
according to politico so wait for it
what's their backup plan let's see if
you can guess
i'm going to give you three seconds to
think of it
correct they're going to shout about
january 6. this is their backup plan
quote
they do rip the bark off house
republicans as quote too dangerous for
american families by focusing on gop
support for trump the january 6th riot
and covet 19 conspiracies
here's the key portion of the dccc memo
the moment washington republicans felt
their grip on power loosen they
unleashed a full assault on american
democracy culminating in a murderous
assault on the capital and the
introduction of anti-voter legislation
around the country every day republicans
demonstrate how unserious cynical and
dangerous their return to power would be
since january 6 republicans have
attempted to block investigations of the
assault cover up their alleged
involvement and have even defended and
celebrated the rioters okay really this
is the law you're going back to january
6th so by the time we hit november of
2022 you think voters are still going to
be focused in on january 6th of 2021
man they are cruising for a serious
bruising come 2022.
and here's the thing you can say that
there are so many look at these
republican crazies these congr crazy
republican congress people most people
in their districts know they're congress
people most of them have already voted
for those congress people it's the
democrats who are going to be on the
defensive right here and so they have a
secondary strategy they're going to yell
about covet quote since day one of this
pandemic they've been hell-bent on
making it longer and more disastrous
denying the seriousness of covet lying
about the effectiveness of mass social
distancing and vaccines
encouraging americans to consume horse
dewormer they're really going to go with
this line even as hundreds of thousands
died and children filled up icu beds
okay first of all again the number of
kids who have died over the course of
the entire pandemic 10 to 20 healthy
children have died according to marty
mccary of johns hopkins
so this is their their pitch their pitch
is that they are going to yell about
january 6th and coven man they are going
to get skunked and they are going to
deserve it they're going to get it so
hard from the american public they have
it coming but don't worry they'll have
the media backing their play every step
of the way so snl
capped off
it's it's season of stupidity with a
with another one of their brilliant
brilliant little sketches this one
starring pete davidson who again i i
will never understand the davidson thing
i'm just never gonna get it i don't
think he's funny i don't think he's
talented
somehow he he
his i will say his dating age range is
quite astonishing it goes all the way
down to like 18 to the low end and up to
apparently like 85 at the upper end
he he like there will be a movie a
remake of harold and maw and starring p
davidson at some point in any case he uh
he did a sketch on snl
with big bird right because because
democrats have been using big birds to
push vaccinations for for children
playing joe rogan
now first of all let me just say this
okay uh pete davidson as joe rogan is
not good casting
like pete davidson is one pound and
about six foot nine
he looks like a bean pole so bad casting
there also he can't tax there's that so
he plays joe rogan and of course we're
just gonna hear the same democratic
talking points on horse dewormer from
snl
i i really you have to wonder why are
democrats so out of touch the reason is
because their cheerleaders in the press
keep telling them that they are doing a
wonderful job here is snl just mirroring
false democratic talking points joe
rogan already destroyed them on
can you help me joe oh sure thing big
bird you see i took carlos mencia down i
could take covet
here's some zinc
an ayahuasca
and some horse medicine
why would a bird take horse medicine i'm
a human and i took horse medicine
and i'm speaking of things that uh are
horse like uh today's two sponsors are
the letters s and d as in i can s my own
d
okay um i have no idea who wrote this or
why they thought it was funny in any way
it's just
the decay of the republic is is upon us
even our comedians are no longer capable
of doing comedy like basic skill sets
have completely faded into oblivion
by the way as joe stated he can afford
people medicine mfr
[Laughter]
all right but guys really keep doubling
down on it keep doubling down on the
commonwealth of it keep doubling down on
the joe biden keep doubling really and
the realities of life are about to hit
democrats square in the face alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington post producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the mat wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show
you